en france les médecins aux intérimaires
sont reçus aujourd'hui par le ministre
de la santé est la loi visant à encadrer
leur salaire a été reportée elle devait
entrer en vigueur dans trois jours mais
le contexte sanitaire plutôt tendue a
changé la donne on va retrouver tout de
suite notre reporter devant le ministère
de la santé david khalifa
[Musique]
bonjour david cette loi s'appelle la loi
risque elle a été reportée en quoi
consiste ne consistait ce texte est
pourquoi olivier vers en fait machine
arrière
et bien magali à l'objectif premier de
ce texte de loi est de mettre fin au
mercenariat de l'intérim médicale en
encadrant pour de bon les rémunérations
versées par les établissements de santé
publique car c'est intérim coûte
beaucoup d'argent à titre d'exemple un
médecin peut toucher jusqu'à 4000 euros
ou plus sain pour une mission d'intérim
des hôpitaux en manque de personnel
acceptent de payer et ses tarifs et vous
en doutez eh bien ça pèse très lourd
dans le budget pourtant la loi indique
que la rémunération de la série médicale
est limité à 1170 euros par tranche de
24 heures depuis 2010 est une limite qui
est difficilement respectée par les
hôpitaux qui sont en tension permanente
la loire east devait encadrer de manière
plus ferme ses prix exubérant le kobe 19
ne fait qu'accentuer ce phénomène et
face à la réalité est des difficultés
bien olivier veyrat n'avait pas le choix
de reporter cette fois à 2022 une
satisfaction pour frédéric valletoux
président de la fédération hospitalière
de france écoutez
l'encadrement de l'intérêt médical est
quelque chose de positif néanmoins c'est
vrai que le contexte n'était pas le
meilleur on plaidait depuis quelques
semaines pour un assouplissement il y as
sans doute à travailler à une charte
avec l'ordre national des médecins avec
les sociétés d'intérim pour qu'elles
respectent le cadre réglementaire et
david certains sénateurs eux accusent
olivier ferrand de reporter un problème
bien plus profond pour l'hôpital public
effectivement et magali un problème de
pénurie de praticiens qui existe depuis
bien longtemps dans l'est dans les
hôpitaux assurer la service la survie
des services hospitaliers les mots sont
forts mais malheureusement bien réel au
pied du mur l'hôpital public n'a pas le
choix bien souvent de recourir à ces
intérimaires qui monte les prix à titre
d'exemple annie le houérou sénatrice cp
s1 des côtes d'armor a pris connaissance
lundi adressé à un établissement de
santé de sa région pour le recrutement
d'un pied d'un pédiatre tarif de la
journée dix mille euros pour 24 heures
c'est tout simplement inadmissible pour
l écouter
je regrette que le gouvernement n'ait
pas trouvé une solution de négociation
avec ses intérimaires qui sont la
plupart du temps des mercenaires qui va
en payer le prix le contribuable et la
santé des patients c'est un scandale ce
sont les intérimaires qui ont encore
gagné le gouvernement aurait dû prendre
des dispositions
la loi une date d'application on doit
l'appliquer une fois de plus c'est faire
fi du parlement
vous l'aurez compris est une certaine
forme de désaveu pour le gouvernement
sénateur vous l'aurez compris c'est une
certaine forme de désaveu pour le
gouvernement sénateurs et députés
montent au créneau repousser ce projet
loi signifie que le ségur de la santé
est loin d'avoir suffire à combler ce
fossé entre les praticiens titulaire et
leurs collègues intérimaires qui plus
est on entre dans une période où la
tension hospitalière est encore plus
présente et l'hôpital pourrait toujours
être à la merci de prétentions
salariales bien au dessus des plafonds
des goûts merci beaucoup david pour
toutes ces précisions on va suivre
évidemment olivier ferrand qui reçoit
donc les médecins intérimaire
aujourd'hui au ministère de la santé